my name is Aditi I'm a PhD student at UC
Berkeley and I'm here to talk to you
about words here and interface for
exploring language use in literary texts
and so now you might be wondering what's
so interesting about literary texts well
the questions that literary scholars ask
of texts are really deep and really
complicated and it takes them a long
time to get answers for our project I
teamed up with Brian Wagner at UC
Berkeley and Brian is studying the
collection of North American slave
narratives these are stories of escaped
former slaves and they're published by
white abolitionists and what Brian is
interested in is characterizing them in
typifying them and so a question that he
might be interested in answering is what
relationship did slaves have with God
and this is a complicated deep question
because to understand it you have to
really have a sense of the entire
collection and you have to get the
answers to what did God do how is God
described unfortunately getting the
answer this question currently takes a
long time and that's because the state
of the art and answering it is to use a
graduate student and so you you pay or
you don't pay this graduate student to
read all the narratives really closely
find passages that deal with the
relationship between slaves and God and
then form a hypothesis and gather
evidence to convince you so there's
clearly a potential for search to speed
up this process we can digitize the
entire collection and index it and so
instead of stumbling around the
narratives looking for passages to deal
with God the graduate student can just
search for them and so that turns it up
it's actually an option for this
collection because it was digitized by
the University of North Carolina and
they put it on a website and so we can
go to a search engine and search the
site we type in God and when we get our
search results we can ask you know what
did God do and how is God described and
stuff like that so here are the search
results and you can see that they're
actually all excerpts from the real
slave narratives so they're sort of
relevant but when you look at them kind
of closely they're not all relevant for
example the first one is only there
because God appears in the title and
many of them don't really have anything
to do with the relationship between
slaves and God and how can you blame it
really sir
and didn't really know what you were
after either way though this is an
improvement than stumbling around the
entire collection instead of having to
read all the narratives closely you only
have to read 37 pages of search results
and that's kind of an improvement right
so to get even a vague sense of what did
God do how's God described instead of
taking five months as would have
previously taken the graduate student
can now do it in maybe a week five days
but the graduate student still has to
spend a lot of time reading each page
that was returned and so why is that why
is there so much reading required what
is it that keyword search is missing
here and the answer is that keyword
search models text as this mysterious
bag of words model sentences in this
juice bags of words where sentences
really aren't mysterious bags of words
sentences follow rules and they have a
grammatical structure and for many years
now it's been possible for computers to
look at that grammatical structure and
automatically understand it so for
example here's a sentence that might
appear in search results the good God
has given every man intellect and on the
left you see the automatically extracted
structure of that sentence using the
structure computers can infer really
interesting and useful things about
relationships between words for example
in the sentence a computer can infer
that God is the agent doing the giving
and that the adjective good applies to
God so in other words what I'm saying is
that it's actually possible to
automatically answer the question what
does God do and how is God described
without having a human necessarily come
and read it and so that's exactly the
approach that we've taken with words
here we want to make it so that a
completely non-technical person can use
this technology and because we're using
the grammatical structure of sentences
we can vastly increase the precision of
the question that you're able to express
instead of just a keyword daaad if
you're after what does God do you can
choose the done by relationship which
pulls out verbs and type in God and if
you're interested in how is God
described you can choose God and say is
described as which pulls out adjectives
and so you could go and of course you
get your list of search results but now
because we're able to scan the entire
collection and pull out words the match
we're able to numerically quantitatively
summarize the entire collection and pull
out words that you would have been
interested in anyway so let's zoom in a
bit what did God do well he blessed he
knew and gave he granted he praised
house God described well he's great he's
just living true holy and so while you
might think that slaves in their misery
would blame God they in fact seem to
have a rather good relationship with him
and the great power of this sort of
technology is that just like that we've
taken what would have taken an
unassisted graduate student five months
to do and maybe five days to do with
search results and reduce it to a
process that just takes five minutes
Thank You Vicky why why is this so hard
we where's the magic here imagine yeah
why is it so hard to do what what is to
do implement this technology possibly
because parsers are kind of slow that it
takes a long time to process and you
know the sentence wouldn't get that kind
of information out of it I'm not sure if
it's a parallelizable mentality they
want to say where's it headed what's
next for this so what's next for this is
we want to actually do a research
project with these historians and
basically convince the humanities that
there's place for this kind of
technology in the humanities and by in
that process convince other people that
you know natural language processing can
actually help answer these really
difficult or researchy questions and can
help speed up the research process right
I wish you lots of success thank you
thank you